hi I'm Tim Shriver I'm the chairman and
CEO of the Special Olympics movement
which is a organization moved all over
the world dedicated to giving people
with intellectual differences chances to
play sports together with their
non-disabled peers by playing sports to
get healthier by getting healthier to
educate the world about their gifts and
their capacity to contribute so I've
been asked what could I is a high school
student what could a high school student
to do to improve the economy in their
country I'll take a step back from the
economy and say first and foremost I
think what high school students need to
do all over the world is believe in
themselves I think they get a lot of
messages that say be discouraged be
dissuaded from fiction accommodate
yourself to whatever's going on in the
world our message the message of the
special exactly tis very different it's
like bring out the best you've got let
it all Ripley on the court go with
everything you've got after what you
believe to be great not good not
accommodating to your teachers or even
your parents I daresay but find that
place of yourself division the
inspiration you've got and let it rep
down go for it the biggest detriment to
economic growth is the lack of
inspiration and imagination that
sometimes we communicate young people
the most important I believe contributed
economics success and economic
revitalization these young people
believe in the new ideas and the
creative energy necessary to marshal
those ideas will bring them to scale
it's not about making money it's about
making ideas coming life I give your
best to your community to the people in
your school into yourself and our
economies will follow you in your future
that's much brighter good luck